coup monté et il avait compris je rigole
pas c'est un coup mais la tête des
vidéos en rien à voir sur mon dos ne pas
en parler parce que voilà alors dit la
vérité puisqu'il s'était resserré ce
code
voilà qu'est ce qui s'est passé face aux
fennecs de paix a dit préférer yann
barthès à vous parce que vous étiez en
dessous de nuit et pas très drôle en
fait sa volée plus ça va aller plus haut
alors on va on à l'extrême et donc dis
moi c'est ma promo sais pas j'ai vu
l'émission et franchement c'est pas
terrible
l'émission de près tout ce qui s'est
passé ce matin l'ex rennais attend avant
dans l'extrait d'accord mais ce matin je
ne regarde jamais ses news
je te jure par hasard j'allume la télé
je tombe sur ses news il ya sûrement que
mon ordi qui cartonne et jean marc
morandini gens que je regarde frédéric
lopez qui parle de l'émission de ce soir
et il lui fait un quiz il lui dit vous
préférez ceux présents de temps mais ça
arrive là toi vous référez yann barthès
vous préférez cyril hanouna way et il
dit je préfère yann barthès dans ma tête
je me dis arrête toi là
l'agrément moi c'est le matin je suis
aussi avec des miels pop se regardent se
tient avec toi là il ya l'émission ce
soir
et là jean marc morandini morandini et
google a l'air tout ça pourquoi on
préférerait yann barthès dans ma tête je
me dis répond parce que ce n'est pas
parce que il ne va pas plus loin et il
dit parce que ça vole plus haut ouais je
me suis dit rajoute un truc des oiseaux
il a vu les oiseaux nés un loto on irait
plutôt il est allé la tête j'appelle
franck ouais j'ai dit franck sûr c'est
vrai j'ai dit franck je parie que ce
soir sert il il parle pas de terrain
connu parce que parce que près de lopez
il a dit qu'il préférait yann barthès
prend qui me dit mais jamais de la vie
jamais de la vie cyril il s'en fout il a
d'autres choses à faire
j'ai le message que tu m'as envoyé à
temps je vais te retrouver le message
dominant c'est vrai à papa ou j'appelle
j'appelle franck à 13h15
13h39 message de cyril hanouna tejero je
ne fais aucune promo ce soir pour le
crédit aux thèses et battu vous sur cet
abruti de frais de la basse mathieu je
te dise quelque chose et c'est ça ça m'a
pas plus abattu que je te dise la vérité
ouais c'est que c'est un deuxième siège
pour toi parce que fred lopez il avec
nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et
attends pas mon club parce que tu as
vécu avec nous ce soir
est-ce que ça va mon père on va t oui
alors évidemment syrie c'était une
blague c'est un coup monté et il avait
compris je rigole pas c'est un coup mais
la tête des vidéos pour les hommes avoué
des frets je voulais te dire mais taxi
ça sort demain ou pas je suis dans le
truman show là je voulais dire que tu
fais ton émission est exceptionnel ce
soir avec malik est ce que tu peux nous
en dire deux mots et nous dire comment
ça s'est passé avec mme annick parce que
c'est fou ce qui s'est passé s'est lui
déjà il croyait partir très très loin et
finalement non tu la mettes dans les
cévennes et je sais qu'il vous l'avait
raconté dans le détail effectivement
donc ils racontent mis au coin
et ce qui est fou c'est que m'a dit vous
allez le voir demain dans un blockbuster
d'un taxi est bien là dans nos terres
inconnues vous le verrez dans les
cascades à 12° vous le montrez vous le
verrez monter à cheval et sans cascadeur
l'un donc sans doublure jamais seul vous
raconter comment ça s'est passé
et vous dire que malik a peur de tout
c'est un euphémisme a discuté et
franchement frédéric je vais te dire
l'émission il paraît que la litote
tout le monde a adoré l'émission je suis
sûr que tu vas faire un carton
d'audience tu sais qu'on est derrière
toi frédéric et j'espère que tu amènera
d'autres potes à moi
loin de tout ça voilà parce que vivre
quand il vit des aventures comme ça
franchement lui ça la change et je te le
dire mais je rigole pas il m'appelait
après il m'a appelé après il m'a peut
être pas pour le tournage m'a pas plu
mais ma paire avons après manif par avec
frédéric lopez jeu plus pouvoir d'avoir
pendant longtemps et quand il est revenu
et m'a dit je suis pas parti loin mais
il m'a raconté
es-tu là tu l'a vraiment changé tu lui
apporter encore je pensais mettre cette
expérience est plein de choix à tout va
et merci branchement cyril pour la
blagounette de ce matin parce que c'est
un coup monté évidemment avec morandini
vous l'avez compris c'est pour faire le
buzz pour faire peur à malik
évidemment vous le savez que ça va le
plus haut chez vous qu'ailleurs mais
enfin ce que vous dites dans l'émission
ce soir sur terre inconnue évidemment on
va beaucoup beaucoup rire ça je peux
vous le dire c'est que malick comme vous
l'avez jamais vu et d'ailleurs franck
gastambide a vu le terrain connu c'est
qu'ils en parlent bien ah ouais
frédéric on sera avec toi soirée juste
après en plus il y aura un débrief en
direct un avec malik haute embrasse très
fort fred merci tu vas pouvoir continuer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]